when i was a sis admin back in pre-cloud  days i had lots of little scheduled  shell scripts on my workstation for  admin tasks like taking backups but now  that many systems are in the cloud it  makes sense to run our admin scripts  there too  let's say we want to run this firestore  database backup every night in the cloud  first we copy this simple go program  that listens for http and invokes our  shell script  finally we deploy the container to cloud  run  if we hit the url of our new cloud run  service our shell script will run at  once  if we set up cloud scheduler to hit that  url the script can run unattended in the  middle of the night it can report status  with the echo command the output will go  to cloud logging where we can look at it  in the morning we should also restrict  access to our cloud run service see the  link in the description now we have a  script that runs nightly without having  to maintain a server or virtual machine  for it